NOT MY NEXT GUEST.
SHE DEFENDS TRUMP EVEN THOUGH
SHE WAS FIRED BY HIM.
>> YOU NOT ONLY LOST.
YOU GOT CREAMED.
YOU KNOW, I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A BIG
OMAROSA FAN, BUT OMAROSA, YOU
ARE FIRED.
THIS WAS NOT CLOSE.
>> THANK YOU FOR BRINGING --
>> THANK YOU MECH.
>> JOINING ME NOW IS OMAROSA
MANIGAULT.
DID I SAY THAT RIGHT?
>> CAN YOU START WITH ME NOT
GETTING FIRED.
>> LET ME INTRODUCE YOU.
FORMER CONTEBS TESTANT.
APPRENTICE, AND FORMER
CONSULTANT FOR VICE PRESIDENT AL
GORE.
>> NO I HAVE GOT TO DIRECT YOU.
I WAS DEPUTY ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF PRESIDENTIAL PERSONNEL.
MY LAST APPOINTMENT WAS IN THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION.
I DID WORK FOR GORK WHICH WAS
TORTURE, BUT THAT WAS FOR A VERY
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
>> AM I FIRED NOW?
>> GET MY CREDENTIAL'S RIGHT,
BOO.
>> HE SPEAKS LIKE THE REALITY
SHOW CELEBRITY THAT'S.
YOU ARE NOT ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
WHO HAS A PROBLEM WITH HIM?
>> I DON'T.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT, I THINK
IT'S JUST SO UNFAIR.
I KNOW YOU SHOULDN'T TALK ABOUT
FAIRNESS.
BUT WHAT A CLASSAL WASTE OF TIME
THAT WE ARE SPENDING ALL OF THIS
TIME TRYING TO INTERPRET WHAT
DONALD TRUMP SAID ABOUT MEGYN
KELLY AS OPPOSED TO GETTING DOWN
TO WHERE HE STANDS ON WOMEN'S
ISSUES.
WE SPECULATED ALL WEEKEND ABOUT
WHETHER HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
HORMONES INSTEAD OF TALKING
ABOUT THE GENDER WAGE GAP OR
FUNDING OR DEFUNDING PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
SHAME ON THE PRESS.
SHAME ON THE MEDIA.
SHAME ON PEOPLE FOR WASTING THE
PEOPLE'S TIME.
>> NO WOMEN PROBLEM, YOU THINK?
>> HE HAS AN AUTHENTIC PROBLEM.
HE IS TOO REAL FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY I HEARD ON YOUR
LAST PANEL THAT YOU WERE SAYING
DONALD TRUMP HAD SOME WAY
DAMAGED THE GOP.
DO YOU KNOW WHO DAMAGED THE GOP?
GEORGE W. BUSH WHEN HE COULDN'T
PRONOUNCE CERTAIN COUNTRIES,
GEORGE W. BUSH WHEN HE DIDN'T
KNOW THE GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION
OF OUR ENEMIES.
SARAH PAY PALIN.
ARE WE SERIOUSLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER OR NOT HE
WOULD MAKE A GOOD PRESIDENT.
HE HAS MAJOR SKILLS.
INSTEAD WE ARE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH A TABLOID HEADLINE.
WE NEED TO TREAT HIM AS A
SERIOUS CANDIDATE.
>> YOU SAID HE IS TOO REAL FOR
THE GOP.
>> YEAH.
>> IS HE TOO REAL, THOUGH TO BE
PRESIDENT?
IT HAS TO TRANSLATE TO OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD.
NOT JUST HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
>> WELL, THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT
HIS TEMPERAMENT IN YOUR LAST
SEGMENT.
HAVE YOU EVER MET KICK CHENEY?
SERIOUSLY.
IF YOU WANT TO MEET SOMEBODY
WITH A TEMPERAMENT PROBLEM.
HE SHOT HIS FRIEND IN THE FACE.
DONALD TRUMP CAN BE PRESIDENT.
HE IS COOL, CALM, HAS HIS NEW
YORK SWAG.
WE NEED A LITTLE OF THAT IN YOUR
FACE.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE HIM GO THAI
TOE TO TOE AGAINST HILLARY
CLINTON ON REAL ISSUES BECAUSE
IF THE GOP KEEPS PLAYING AROUND
WITH DONALD TRUMP, HE IS GOING
TO SLIDE RIGHT IN THERE AND
STEAL THAT NOMINATION AND WE
WILL SEE THE BEST DEBATE IN
HISTORY.
HILLARY RODHAM CLINTON, DONE J.
TRUMP.
>>> ASKED HIM THIS QUESTION ON
FRIDAY, IF YOU ARE GOING TO
STANDS UP AGAINST PUTT SKPIN
CHINA AND ALL OF THAT, BUT THEN
YOU GET UPSET WHEN SOMEONE LIKE
MEGYN KELLY ASKS YOU A TOUGH
QUESTION -- A QUESTION THAT MANY
PEOPLE SAW AS FAIR.
HE DIDN'T SEE IT AS FAIR BUT I
THINK MOST OTHER PEOPLE SAW IT
AS FAIR -- THEN HOW ARE YOU
GOING TO NEGOTIATE WITH WORLD
LEADERS IF YOU ARE VIEWED AS SO
THINNED SKINNED.
YOU DON'T THINK HE IS THIN
SKINNED?
>> NO.
I HAVE BEEN ON THE RECEIVING END
OF ONE OF DONALD TRUMP'S WRATHS.
HE IS TOUGH BUT FAIR.
HE OPENED UP DONALD TRUMP DUE
BY.
THERE WERE WORLD LEADERS AT THIS
EVENT.
TALKED TO THEM.
I MET PEOPLE FROM INDIA, ASIA,
RUSSIAN.
THEY WERE THERE, THEY LOVED HIM.
HE KNOWS HOW TO NEGOTIATE ON AN
INTERNATIONAL STAGE.
DO NOT UNDERESTIMATE THE POWER
OF DONALD TRUMP OR YOU WILL BE
SCRATCHING YOUR HEAD WONDERING
HOW DID HE GET THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION.
>> YOU KNOW, HE IS GOING TO BE
FOCUSING MORE ON POLICY IS WHAT
WE ARE -- YOU HAVE BEEN CALLED A
HIGH HARD DEMOCRAT, SOME SAY
THAT TRUMP IS MORE --
>> I AM.
>> MORE OF A DEMOCRAT THAN A
REPUBLICAN WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICY.
SO WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT --
WHAT PEOPLE CALL HIS FLIP-FLOPS
ON ISSUES, LIKE HEALTH CARE,
LIKE ABORTION?
BEFORE YOU ANSWER THAT.
>> WELL, YEAH.
>> EVEN IN THE DEBATE THERE WAS
A QUESTION THAT SAID -- I THINK
MEGYN SAID WHEN DID YOU BECOME A
REPUBLICAN?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK HAVING BEEN
IN POLITICS SINCE I WAS 13 YEARS
OLD I CAN TELL YOU THAT PEOPLE
EVOLVE, PEOPLE CHANGE.
EVEN I CHANGED.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW I RAN
FOR SCHOOL BOARD.
AND SUDDENLY PEOPLE ARE ASKING
ME MY OPINION ABOUT CERTAIN
THINGS, CERTAIN ISSUES.
THERE WAS MY PERISCOPE, SORRY.
ABOUT CERTAIN ISSUES I HAD NEVER
THOUGHT ABOUT BEFORE.
SO THEN I HAD TO START TO
CONCEIVE AND THINK ABOUT MY
POSITIONS.
EVEN THOUGH I HAD SAID THINGS
BEFORE, IF I DIDN'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION I COULDN'T FORMULATE
CLEAR POLICY.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING,
DONALD TRUMP IS HIRING THE BEST
POLICY ANALYSTS THAT MONEY CAN
BUY.
HE IS BEING ADVISED BY THE BEST.
WHEN HE PUTS HIS POSITION PAPERS
OUT BELIEVE ME, THEY ARE GOING
TO BE SOLID, REFLECT WHERE HE
STANDS ON ISSUES.
AND YOU WON'T BE SCRATCHING YOUR
HEAD.
BY THE WAY, HE IS NOT THE ONLY
ONE.
I WENT TO JEB BUSH'S WEBSITE --
ANY DON'T HAVE CLEAR POLICY
POSITION US BECAUSE IT'S STILL
VERY EARLY.
>> OMAROSA, YOU ARE FIRED.
JUST FROM THIS SEG MERCHT
BECAUSE IT'S